here we go one of the big events this
year was the opening of resorts world
and one of their must try restaurants is
marigold and we are so excited to have
chef robert garcia joining us today
welcome to the show
thank you guys thank you for having me
here we're so excited we're excited to
have you here i've heard so many great
things about the restaurant for someone
that hasn't been there before describe
the atmosphere of the restaurant well
this is uh first of all
uh this is the fun stuff that we've been
doing like for the past well like three
months i would say yes to three months
can't remember exact
uh this is a local restaurant you know
like family owned and operate so
when you walk in there you get like an
old vegas like palm springs vibe to the
place yeah we just you know we wanted to
bring something back from you know the
like say you know like palm springs and
all vegas style we wanted to make
something very
simple
uh
and different at the same time so we
kind of tweak it a little bit we have a
lot of variety lobster burgers i mean
who doesn't love burgers right burgers
lobsters your desserts the buzz is about
your lobster rolls that's correct so
many different lobster rolls what are
you gonna make for us today uh we're
going to make here
our
one of us signature laughter rolls is
the vegas lofty roll uh we make it
you want to put it together now put it
together describe to me what you're
putting in the vegas roll so this is our
lobster meat here okay first of all
we're gonna
toss our brioche rolled with butter
make sure we make it like super nice and
toasty
uh and then we're gonna add
our dill aioli
we're gonna put a little bit on we're
just going to mix it up a little bit
who came up with this creation of the
vegas lobster roll was this your idea uh
that was actually our billy you know or
you know the owner of the company
yeah so we just master it you know
lobster yes what else goes into this
rolls you put the top so yeah so we put
the you know we put the lobster meat we
toss it a little bit with the uh dill
aioli a little bit of fresh diced fennel
you know that's what it makes it that's
what it makes it all the flavor come
together is that a little bit does that
add some crunch to it as well that's
right yeah a little bit of texture yes
sir
yeah come on i know my lobster rolls
rocky a little texture i know these
things unlv i know so we're going to so
we're going to stop the loft roll all
right okay i got to wrap it up here but
we're stepping this is the finished
product right here and is this booney on
top of your lobster that's correct
that's correct
on top of anything makes it delicious
there you go
this yes sir all right chef thank you so
much marigold at resorts world go right
ahead
feel good las vegas now we'll